j'ai reçu le Xiaomi 13 pro alors qu'il
est pas encore sorti en France c'est
aujourd'hui le smartphone le plus haut
de gamme de Xiaomi avec un grand écran
OLED de 6,73 pouces qui a un taux de
rafraîchissement qui va de 1 à 120 Hertz
on est en plus ici processeur le plus
puissant le stade dragon 8 GN2 avec un
score sur un toutou qui fera pas lire la
concurrence on a 8 ou 12 Go de RAM c'est
à 5x et 128 256 ou 512 Go en ufs 4.1 une
grosse batterie de 482 avec de la
recharge
qui vous le recharge jusqu'à 100%
seulement 19 minutes on a trois capteurs
50 mégapixels réalisés en partenariat
avec Leica le premier capteur c'est un
capteur de 1 pouce c'est la Sony MX 989
on a aussi un téléobjectif de 50
mégapixels qui est également stabilisé
et un ultra grand angle qui permet
également de prendre des photos en
Macron bien évidemment les colorimétrie
Leica pour retrouver l'ambiance des
photos les cas du wifi 6 IP68 bref un
smartphone hyper sexy qui n'est pas
encore sorti en France donc je peux pas
vous donner le tarif en France mais qui
arrivera très bientôt d'ailleurs
dites-moi est-ce que le Xiaomi 13 pro
pourrait vous intéresser par quel mode
dans les commentaires